shadan and her family got to dunkirk
last night the final stop on their way
to britain
how many in this tent
eight eight people in this tent two
children it's not where she wants her
children to sleep but they make do as
best they can
are you would you worry about it being
dangerous on boats
yeah not tulish
yeah
[Music]
this family are from iraq like so many
others here waiting for their chance to
make the crossing
slowly hearing about the people who lost
their lives on wednesday like mariam who
was one of at least 27 to die in the
channel she is trying to join her fiance
in england they are like our family
nothing is different between me and
others peoples
we feel
they're playing they play with their
lives
and do you think you now are going to
try to go on a boat too no no never i
will not strive for because i don't want
to play with my life
the camps here are sprawled behind the
coastline
this is loon beach where you think the
boat set off on wednesday
you don't have to look far here to find
evidence of channel crossings and this
is the challenge of patrolling this
stretch of northern france there's more
than 100 kilometers of beach where boats
can set off from and all they have to do
is make it the short distance down the
beach into the water and once they're at
sea there's very little that police can
do
two survivors an iraqi and a somali are
being questioned in this building in
calais and as police work out how this
tragedy unfolded a familiar diplomatic
dynamic has resurfaced with boris
johnson accused of grandstanding and the
home secretary disinvited from a summit
tomorrow what we need to do now is is go
even further really further strengthen
that partnership think about what else
we can do in terms of the deployment of
technology and yes suggestions about
doing joint patrols uh reciprocal
maritime
activity um perhaps even co-insignia on
aerial surveillance there are more
things we can do for all the politics
the diplomatic stalemate in the middle
are the migrants
still waiting still determined to make
it to britain ali fortescue sky news in
calais